they've known everything for years I
it's amazing isn't it how anyone who
disagrees with them has got to be just
crazy Lieutenant Shaw reporting his
ordered
sir what's the fight even about I guess
I just can't abide bullies sir your
father threw a few punches in this day
some of them and
me some orders have come through see
security escort for a Japanese scientist
sorry sir a Japanese scientist I think
you here for
me you like me to drive
[Music]
why am I making you
nervous it's
impressive doesn't that make you a
little overqualified for this snipe hunt
this what wild goose
chase
help hurry help come on help
oh oh my God oh my God help me get him
out come on more comes back
okay it is a
dragon you want to do some serious
science then we need backing welcome to
Monarch
General if we hide who we are and what
we're trying to do then what's the point
point of doing it at
all
okay it's over it's
over I don't trust either of
us I don't
care yes you
do
oh my
God why would he have that in this
file we didn't kill
it oh my
God oh my God go go
go reach K
reach you don't have to do
this
hurry mayday
mayday mayday
mayday
[Music]
I told you I've been here before and I
made it
back get me Bill R you disappeared
during operation hour class in
1962 20 years
ago just station will last about 5 and a
half months with the majority occurring
during if I tell you the truth you're
just going to think I'm be's Adventure
now begins as it searches for sources we
interrupt this program to bring you
breaking
[Applause]
[Music]
news Colonel
Shaw we can get the hell out of here
right now and find out what really
happened with your
dad
oh my God stop come on
baby here we
go everybody in one piece back
there Run come on get my
rocks what what happened to your
centuries of experience it's a Titan May
they're like
snowflakes never came across two that
were the same we built a bonfire we feed
it dinner time you son of
a the world is on
fire I decided to do something about it
mhm you you want to help Monarch is
[Music]
wrong I think you and I have a lot to
talk about come with me you'll know
everything I promise you my name is
Colonel Leland Lafayette Shaw
III and your base is now under my
control
sir
look what exactly do you think we'll
find in
there
R it won't be for the faint of heart I
can tell you that so that's why you want
to seal off their world I am sealing off
their
world every
portal
I got
you don't let go of
[Applause]
[Music]
me